another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation dr bright stop  gaslighting people gaslighting is a form  of psychological manipulation where  someone deliberately attempts to get  another person to question their very  perception of reality and even their own  sanity in short it's not a very nice  thing to do it's especially not nice or  permitted in any way for dr bright to  attempt to gaslight various foundation  staff into thinking that they in fact  are the real dr bright we're not sure  what you're attempting to accomplish  there doctor but it's me and we're tired  of paying for the therapy bills